I didn't think anything was going to  happen in Vegas because he portrayed  himself as a really religious man and he  stuck through his morals throughout the  relationship and so I thought this was  just a regular weekend on the Sunday  that he was coming home he came to my  house unannounced panic in his eyes and  just like pale like he looked really  scared and I was just confused on what  happened and then that's when he  admitted to the cheating he admitted to  doing things with some of the  bachelorette party it's funny because  those girls knew who I am and I know one  of them was a close friend to mine too  and I was just  broken and then after he came and  confessed what he did I had to go to  work I had to go to work at Disneyland  the happiest place on earth